das sind wirklich ziemlich kuriose
ähnlichkeiten zwischen menschen und
tieren schon alleine 98% uns erbgutes
teilen wir mit den schimpansen und auch
bei anderen säugetieren liegen die
genetischen gemeinsamkeiten bei
mindestens 80 prozent im tierreich gibt
es viele arten deren gewohnheiten sehr
stark an das verhalten der menschen
erinnern zum beispiel ameisen die sich
nutztiere halten oder aber delfine die
sich beim namen nennen wir haben die
drei kuriosesten und spannendsten
beispiel dafür und das spannendste finde
ich die menschliche charakterzüge bei
tieren die sind schon ziemlich fertig
zum science-fiction-epos eklig
spannendes seines videos abonnieren den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's platz drei
delfine die sich beim namen nennen in
der fachsprache ist von einer
sogenannten re fancy allen kommunikation
die rede gemeint ist damals die tatsache
dass sich delfine tatsächlich mit namen
ansprechen die tiere signalisieren mit
signatur pfiffen nicht nur ihre eigene
identität sondern treten auch mit ihren
artgenossen in kontakt die delfine
lernen ihren eigenen signatur pfiff
schon in der kindheit und zwar indem sie
den geräuschen in ihrer umgebung
lauschen daraus entwickeln sie dann ihr
ganz eigenes muster an fünf lauten ihre
namensnennung und die rufen die delfine
sagen immer wieder ins meer hinaus ihre
artgenossen hören dass und imitieren die
flaute ein britisches forschungsteam hat
dieses phänomen genauer untersucht vor
allem wollten die fachleute klären ob es
sich dabei tatsächlich um das rufen der
namen handelt oder ob die tiere mit dem
flotten etwas anderes bieten
beispielsweise imitieren vogelmenschen
ja die strophe eines nachbarn menschen
und wollen ihn damit zum kampf
auffordern doch weil ihnen denn vielen
ist das anders wenn die biologinnen und
biologen dann herausfanden
denn vor allem kamen diese fünf kopien
bei tieren vor die ein sehr enges
verhältnis zueinander haben wie bei
müttern und ihren jungen beispielsweise
fest steht also bei den meeressäugern
handelt es sich tatsächlich um eine
individuelle ansprache
das war so im tierreich bisher noch
nicht bekannt platz zwei ameisen halten
sich nutztiere und sklaven wir menschen
halten uns hühner kühe und schweine als
nutztiere bei den ameisen sind es
blattläuse sie dienen in quasi als
melkkühe die den ameisen läuse tod
liefern
honigtau ist dann vielleicht
schönere bezeichnung um die läuse zu
melken klopfen die ameisen ihnen an die
hinterbeine in ihren ameisenhaufen
richten die tiere extra kann man ein
oder besser stelle für die läuse haltung
manche von ihnen dürfen aber auch in der
freilandhaltung leben und die leistung
der blattläuse ist warte ich bis zu
sieben tropfen honig zu können manchem
blattläuse pro stunde ausscheiden dass
es wahnsinnig viel wenn man bedenkt dass
diese menge ihr eigenes körpergewicht
übersteigt pro jahr ernten die ameisen
so zehn kilogramm getrocknete blattlaus
zucker
doch manche ameisenarten gehen sogar
noch weiter und halten sich sogar
sklaven diesen phänomenen hatte schon
charles darwin beobachtet vor allem die
harmlos axa meisten verhalten sich wie
echte sklavenhalter ein deutsches
forschungsteam hat der letztes jahr
herausgefunden dass diese ameisenarten
durch gene getrieben werden um ihnen die
fremde nester zu gelangen setzen die
ameisen chemische duftstoffe ein so dass
sie von den anderen ameisen nicht als
eindringlinge enthaart werden können
reguliert werden diese duftstoffe über
spezifische angriffs gehen dann töten
die sklavenhalter die arbeiterinnen der
byrds kolonie wobei es zu heftigen
kämpfen kommt dass es vor allem der fall
wenn eine königin in der kolonie lebt
wohnen die ameisen dort ohne königin
manipulieren die sklavenhalter ameisen
die arbeiterinnen der wirz kolonie
diese werden somit gezwungen die brut
der eigenen kolonie in das netz der
sklavenhalter ameisen zu bringen die als
sklaven gehalten ameisen müssen nicht
nur für ein sauberes netz sorgen sondern
auch futter heran schaffen und die bot
der unterdrücker versorgen das
aggressive verhalten dieser tenno thorax
ameisen ist der aktuellen studie zufolge
auf zwei bestimmte gene zurückzuführen
platz eins tiere haben menschliche
charakterzüge forschungsteams weltweit
sind sich einig dass auch tiere einen
individuellen charakter haben zum
beispiel zeigt sich dass bei
einsiedlerkrebse bei gefahr verstecken
sie sich in ihrem gehäuse doch wie
schnell sie dann wieder mit ihren beinen
und antennen herauskommen das ist
individuell ganz unterschiedlich die
mutigen einsiedlerkrebse trauen sich
schon nach einigen sekunden wieder
heraus und erhöhen damit ihre chance
nahrung zu finden
dabei sind sie aber auch dem risiko
ausgesetzt selbst beute zu werden
bei den einsiedlerkrebse mit einem
vorsichtigen wesenszug ist es genau
anders herum die überlebenschancen der
gesagt
population steigt wenn sie sich aus
einem bunten mix aus verschiedenen
eigenschaften zusammensetzt ein
charakterzug der übrigens auch bei
vielen menschen zu finden ist zeigt der
drei stachlige stichling vor allem wenn
ein eher ängstlicher charakter
dahintersteckt trumpft dieser fisch mit
einem imposanten auftreten und einer
richtigen rüstung auf gemeint ist ein
dicker brustpanzer und längere stachel
die persönlichkeit der fische wird vor
allem durch die umwelt und den vater der
die jungen alleine erzieht geprägt wenn
die fische in einem gewässer groß werden
in dem es viele fressfeinde gibt bringen
die fische ihren nachkommen bei
vorsichtig zu sein
heraus kommen dann eher ängstliche
stichlinge die mithilfe ihres auftretens
lassen ganz nach dem motto große klappe
nichts dahinter
übrigens gibt es eine weitere
gemeinsamkeit zu uns menschen der eher
schüchternen stichlinge machen das was
zurückhaltenden menschen auch gerne tun
sie suchen sich gute und enge freunde
die extrovertierten fischer haben zwar
auch kontakt zu anderen
dieser verteilt sich aber gleichmäßig
auf alle mitglieder der gruppe zudem
unternehmen die mutigen fische auch mehr
im alleingang pflanze spürt schmerzen
können pflanzen fühlen also anklicken
anschauen und unbedingt making lab
abonnieren denn dieser kanal hat bald
seine hunderttausend abos zusammen und
wird diese grenze knacken also
unterstützt dabei und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran